q4 of last year we started to see an
abating of coveted stats not as much as
we wanted but they started to move q1 of
this year we saw a little bit more
abating of covet stats and what happened
in q1 of this year pat all the economic
stats started coming out we started
realizing what was going on with
employment usa today
map of
covet cases rising
and i believe in q1 of this year djt
would have called china and said hey you
know kovitz turning the corner we're
getting good visibility and line of
sight on a lot of these economic stats
wtf and he would have had an economic
summit in q1 of this year when we had
the stats and we looked like we were
moving on covid and at that point we
also had unemployment we had labor stats
we had a lot of other things going on
and at that point he would have said
holy crap we're being gamed and he would
have made the phone call and had an
economic summit
have been multiple delegations flying
over there there's my direct yes yes
trade delegation import export balancing
act threatening of the tariffs coming
back
about how many times minutes on an
airplane
think about how many times i believe
janet yellen has not janet yellen hadn't
gotten she couldn't find an airplane
it this is ridiculous and by the way
winter's coming
winter's coming tell us what this chart
is to tom's point there wasn't there was
a window of opportunity to tom's point a
month ago four of those states a month
ago four of the states had rising
coveted cases yeah i'm not rewriting
history i'm just going back where were
we q4 q1 and what sort of stuff were you
talking about there was an opportunity
then
the opportunity window's closing because
now you have the vast majority of u.s
states with rising covet cases
the vast majority yeah we're back
looking internally yeah all the cold
states where you have to be in texas
is oklahoma texas is arizona cold is new
mexico cold read the map danielle those
those parts are started it starts reds
are growing all the cold states
in texas all the northeast texas is red
oklahoma is red texas is not red daniels
it's gray what
texas is red buddy texas is red i'm not
blind texas red you okay
oh i'm looking at the actual map here
the cat's really confusing you isn't it
no it's okay so what's going on there
with the gray what new cases are steady
there is no steady there's there's why
the hell does it have a grey box there
because sometimes cases hold steady so
where's the gray why show it
adam you're okay because there is no
grade it's either growing or shrinking
there is something what the f is the
point of showing a gray box there call
the editors at usa today and tell them
to take off
then well then we'll we'll i'll i'll
send a memo
i'll tweet out to usa today if it means
texas that's great and i don't know i'm
gonna tweet it out right now you're
showing me texas is not great when it's
[ __ ] great okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
tweet out unbelievable editors at usa
today the state of texas is gray you're
like no it's not gray it's red okay i
love this it's red so they don't like it
the way they have it the design
absolutely i agree the design is
horrible so please remove nancy can you
please help these guys out let's help
create a better design than these guys
have so if you don't why not just have
the states so
so let me let me let me read that though
because what she is talking about is
uh what's going on right now with covet
cases what page is that by the way what
page is that we had it as something we
wanted to talk about
because danny okay there you go page
number seven let me go to page number
seven so uh us u.s covert case start to
rise again as a holiday uh approaches
this is an npr story it's a worrying
sign for the us out of the holiday
season coronavirus infection arising
more than half of the state's experts
warned this could be a start of an
extended winter surge the rise is a
turnaround after cases had steadily
declined from mid-september to late
october the country is now averaging
around 83 000 cases a day about 14
increase compared to a week ago that's a
pretty solid increase in a week by the
way and 12 percent more than two weeks
ago
growth in cases isn't expected isn't
unexpected given the patchwork of cover
19 immunity across the u.s where about
60 of population is fully vaccinated as
we head into the holidays covet risk
increases with more people traveling and
socializing indoors but we also have
some things that are helping like more
vaccines and kids getting vaccinated
says doctor
jia dean of brown university school of
public health um
you know the other day i saw a video
of uh
health uh health and services going to
houses knocking on doors on apartments
saying do you need coveted shots do you
need vaccine shots do you need vaccine
shots this is in houston the same in
california this is in houston and then
disney just announced that they're doing
their cruises did you hear about
disney's cruise so they just announced
they're doing cruise disney cruises back
only but kids five years and above have
to be vaccinated to get on these cruise
ships here's what's crazy about it 90 of
disney cruises leave florida what are
you gonna do with florida these kids are
you're leaving a state like this you
should be doing it more from california
than from here so or seattle yeah what
what's your twitter handle again do you
need to google that talks money
so
so is is this something that concerns
you with cova cases going up
honestly i had one sign
this week that we are officially moving
past cope there was one sign
the the country uh the concert you went
to or i was at that country con so we
could talk about that too
uber
is now back
to doing liverpool
did you hear what i said uberpool is
back uberpool okay
i let us say today and i thought you do
on it just launched uh please i said so
we're bothering
what's my point that's a dumb design
what is your what's my point
uber has eliminated uberpool lyft at
lyft used to have lift share
all throughout covet you could not do
uberpool you're not none of that
hey it is officially and now i landed in
fort lauderdale they're like you don't
have to wear a mask anymore in uber
welcome to florida no no this is
nationwide okay
so that told me uber big tech silicon
valley california they said all right
we're back to business as usual that's a
big deal to put two random people in a
car together in a ride share
the fact that that is now a thing that
that's a telltale sign that we're moving
past is pandora so uber pool
tells you we're moving past pandemic it
doesn't tell it's an indicator is that
uber pool only for florida or across the
country i don't know i haven't it's
probably the only floor yeah okay maybe
in florida if you look at it is what
color
it's apparently gray slash blue yeah
okay so florida are we are we all right
here do we need to get an optometrist
immediately i just think it's a dumb map
just make the map you put the boxes on
like them
usa today
they will get back to me shortly i
promise let's do that so okay so i'm
afraid
so the benefit the benefit is you live
in florida and you have no idea what
it's like in california cause i told you
i was in california this week last week
for wedding and at the wedding i went to
cross stations i told the story last
week what happened so california tried
to use the bathroom yeah he's like
everything is a mess you can't eat
inside you can only eat outside as of
november 4th the only people that can
eat inside are the ones that are fully
vaccinated you know they have their
passport and i don't carry my
vaccination passport card i don't like
to do that right right i know because
it's concerned it's very heavy i don't
like to carry my password when i'm
traveling domestic i don't watch it you
just have to take a photograph of that
on your phone
in new york peeing on the side of the
building what are they saying nothing
they say thank you for not using a
bathroom inside standards have changed
but no they let me use the bathroom but
the the challenge was you know it is
still mass counting did you actually
have to use the bathroom or you're
thinking all right let's see what they
say about this
actually jennifer had to use a bathroom
and i was asking on her behalf but i
also wanted to have some fun with myself
i figured that i know i know you because
my bladder is a once a day twice a day
type of deal but uh it is way too much
information yeah well the people that
know me they know what's what what that
had nothing to do with four arnold
palmers yeah no nothing to do with
foreign minimum okay so were you going
to say something about these covet cases
like you're saying this was their
opportunity they had their opportunity
to dot that out like how how bad can
this look be if this thing goes
look right right
okay there are two there are two sets of
individuals in america who are upset by
inflation the most
i mean a lot of people are like the 999
oscar and bacon i'm still upset
because we eat like a pound a week in
the house and i'm like no bacon for you
so i didn't buy it i'm like [ __ ] sorry
it's cute no no no no bacon i didn't buy
the bacon okay no that's no i'm sorry
you didn't buy the bacon just out of
principle you can't afford the baby out
of principal no the kids are not you
know what right now you know what on
wednesday they put a coupon in my little
tom thumb flyer and you can get two uh
limit two with my electronic coupon for
3.99 each danielle di martino booth is
using coupons to go grocery shopping i
always use coupons don't you completely
no i don't know coupons it's pretty easy
even for you like to have something
called an app do you know what an app is
they have an app and you just you just
download the difference
we'll understand all of that stuff when
he gets married so keep going keep going
you're talking about 4333 you're talking
about bacon wrap bacon
so
there was an opportunity but who's upset
by inflation the most the lowest income
earners we get that we get that right
and people over the age of 65. because
they're fixed incomes and who holds the
vast majority of savings in america
people 65. and what happens when their
state turns red if they're over 65
a lot of them they have to stay home
they get mandated and da da da da well
in the case of in the case of my mother
or my aunt who are in their 70s
they feel like they're they're kind of
compelled to stay home until they get to
the you know until their their little
state turns
blue again so you've got all of these
all of these savings in the hands of
older individuals who are freaking out
about inflation didn't they just get a
social security let me tell you there's
a whole it gives a whole new meaning to
winter is coming they just got more
money though
if you look in the aggregate if you look
in the aggregate u.s household savings
in absolute numbers are where they were
prior to the pandemic all of that
stimulus money that was pissed into the
wind is gone
no it's not it's in the ebitda of the of
companies oh yes you really think
general motors
kelly blue book came out a few days ago
and said that
cali bluebird came out a few days ago
and said that the average car in america
is forty six thousand dollars forty six
thousand three hundred dollars
new car prices have gone up eight months
in a row
they've taken incentives away nobody can
convince me nobody can provide a
convincing case that because there's a
semiconductor shortage by the way
inventory car inventories are rebuilding
and they're rebuilding rapidly nobody
can tell me that that all of these car
makers didn't raise the prices of cars
more than they needed to because they
could
stick it to them what are you going to
say you're going to say no you don't
have a choice you got to do it because
inventory's down so here we go i can
increase it yeah but their inventories
are rising again so again winter's
coming so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you